Kylie Jenner's daughter story makes her  snapchat debut I love it it's the little  things that count and Kylie can't get  enough of her little girl posting this  sweet video of the newborns tiny toes on  social media Sunday the new mom has been  gushing over baby stormy since giving  birth to her and Travis Scott's first  child earlier this month  today although the reality star has yet  to reveal her daughter in full she's  been slowly sharing bits and pieces of  her private life again on social media  including who stormy resembles Kylie  tweeted staring at her all day she looks  just like me when I was a baby and fans  got a glimpse of the lavish gift Kylie  got from her boyfriend and baby's father  after becoming a first-time mom and all  black Ferrari push present  [Music]